the Betsy gave me this little title of
system change you know I feel a lot of
pressure when she gives me something
like that it's a source as Wednesday
morning you guys are halfway through
this and then she says I just want to
talk about this one little thing which
is trying to change immense systems you
know I'm sure you can do it in about an
hour and you know these people are
traveling very far they are jet like the
first couple days so Wednesday they're
finally feeling like they're in the time
zone and now if you can just give them
those secrets of what it takes to be to
change because that would be really
great you know then then they can go
home with something and make these big
differences and I I felt an immense
amount of pressure with that but I will
tell you that I also come into this
lecture with a great amount of humility
because you know the truth is anyone up
here who is giving a talk that doesn't
really know the challenges that you face
on the ground and your country that you
face day to day and you know the the
challenges are different than our
challenges and they're quite immense but
what I thought I would do in this talk
is to try to reflect a little bit on
some of the experiences we've had and
maybe maybe some of those experiences
have parallels to even as the targets of
our attention are different and even as
some of our methods may be a little bit
different I think some of the themes
might be relevant and we're thinking
about the general underlying principles
of our work are based on the idea that
we're trying to promote within our
health care system effectiveness in
efficiency and equity and patient
centeredness in timeliness
responsiveness of care and safety within
that care so these are the general
properties that are institute of
medicine when we convened experts
together came up and said these are the
properties of a sophisticated
well-functioning health care system and
what's interesting I'm a cardiologist
and within my field there is a great
effort to try to get people to be
looking this big at problems instead of
looking at it as a sort of interrelated
problems that
touch patients and fields of medicine
and social determinants of health and
trying to understand the integrated
solutions so I'm taught in many
reputable institutions about how to
think very small but the problems
actually require a large integrated
vision and so it's no wonder that within
medicine we have people who are in
general poorly equipped to actually
address the major problems that are
facing us because our whole frame of
reference our whole way of looking at
problems tends to be a very much
fragmented very not very holistic or
integrated across the entire entire
problem our belief are working in the
work that we've done is that we can
actually bring about mark improvements
in health greater productivity out of
our healthcare system much greater
efficiencies by just thinking about the
organization of care the way in which
knowledge is transferred to the point of
care the integration of that knowledge
also into societal policies and that
this is as powerful as powerful as any
new medication that's likely to come up
and to promote better care now look I
would love to see a malaria vaccine I
would love to see scientific
breakthroughs that will transform our
ability to help patients but I also know
that these breakthroughs will mean
nothing if they don't have a means by
which they can be appropriately
transferred to the population in need
and this is another new concept within
academics you know the whole value
system within academics is built solely
on academic productivity my promotion
was largely based on the quality and
number of publications that I had in the
grants that I could attract now we have
begun to shift this view because what
good are the
papers if they're not generating
knowledge which have a pathway to
application that are fundamentally going
to better people's lives and this is a
change this is a change because the
former paradigm is it's not my job to
carry that water it's not my job to make
that step my job is only to produce
knowledge and often without the
interaction with the people whose lives
I'm trying to better so I'm sitting up
here saying I think this is what you
need to know and I'm trying to study
things and produce knowledge that I
think you should listen to and then when
you don't listen it doesn't mean you I
mean it can be any you when you don't
listen that's your problem i don't know
why you don't listen and when people's
lives are not bettered from it well what
fault is that of mine we're trying to
change that view we're trying to say how
do we begin to think about the
generation of knowledge and at the time
we're generating the knowledge pay
attention to its proper application and
also to generate knowledge about that
application because ultimately at the
end of our lives when we look back what
we will not we will care about are the
lives that we have touched the people
who have been potentially saved that we
never met because of improvements in the
way the system operates we won't care
about the number of papers we won't care
about knowledge that didn't go anywhere
its of no use the only of use to me in
my promotion that's a very selfish
approach now there still are some people
who are ill-suited for that next step
and really ought to just focus on
knowledge generation but we've got to
get them even if they can't participate
in thinking that next step to hone their
questions to the questions we need and
to be working at least with people who
are involved in that translation now
there's another important piece to this
I think in terms of the experience which
is that the science is actually
important
now sometimes when we're working and
trying to make improvement we actually
think you know the science we cannot
have time for the science well that's up
to us to refine the science the science
to me means the science to me means that
we are taking the time to try to deeply
understand what we are accomplishing and
how we can continue to do better we are
testing hypotheses about what the best
approaches are we are learning from our
experience I can't tell you how much in
this country how much experience is
wasted patient after patient treated new
idea after new organizational idea tried
and because we are not systematically
evaluating the experience we do not have
any idea about whether it is any good it
is our own testimony based on our
anecdotal experience based on our own
opinions that that seems like it's a
good idea but we haven't taken the time
to organize ourselves to say we really
need to learn from what we are doing so
that tomorrow we can feed that new
knowledge back and that is legitimate
science that is important science
because as we continue to spiral up in
our performance it is only going to be
because of these insights so this is AMA
like I said I'm just a cardiologist but
I'm someone who's departed from the sort
of central main stream of my profession
because when I started they said well
what do you want to do do you want to be
a person who focuses on images of the
heart or do you want to be a person who
focuses on certain procedures like
angioplasty or are you a diseased person
do you want to focus on heart failure or
do you want to focus on heart attacks
and i said no i want what i want to
focus on is improving our ability to
help people and i want to know that my
work is better in people's lives that's
what we want to try to make more
mainstream as we have these kind of
conversations and so that will stretch
from the biology to the clinical arenas
to the social and political areas within
the countries because our accountability
our success is only going to be measured
when we can demonstrate that lives have
been bettered because of the efforts and
that i believe is as relevant to your
countries as it is to mine and it's mere
I don't say merely but it is a matter
only of committing to the careful
evaluation of what we're doing and the
humbleness to say we know we can do
better no matter how we're doing and we
have to be able to feed more information
back and reflect and not be defensive
but say we what can we do here do it you
can be done better so what I wanted to
do today was too so I have it's like a
play I don't know I so I you know it's
dangerous sometimes when you start
reading books so I read this book that
it's called beyond bullet points it says
that we shouldn't be Betsy I don't know
if she agrees with me but you shouldn't
be giving talks with all of these bullet
points because especially in the morning
given people this is closest I get to
bullet points their numbers with the you
know that the presentation should
stimulate ideas so you will see I don't
have many bullet points I'm trying to i
think if i make it like a play then
you'll maybe a i can keep your attention
a little bit more i heard that a
presentation supposed to be part
entertainment part content i don't know
you can tell me what you think but what
i want to start with is the lessons that
I've learned personally from my
experiences here again i would never
pretend to tell you what you should be
doing in your place I think part of this
experience is about listening to
different ideas in trying to figure out
what might be good to try what might not
be but you should never hear someone
like me tell yo that you have to do this
because only you know all of the
different things that are challenging
you and how you can best incorporate
that then I want so I want to talk about
some brief lessons I've learned in this
journey for me I want to show you a
couple of
samples of things that we've done and
how we've done them at least to the best
of my ability and then talk about what
might be some next steps and then I hope
we can have some conversations perhaps
about some of these issues so one thing
I've learned is that look I'm very
committed I'm a trained also in
epidemiology I believe strongly in
understanding the larger numbers but I
learned early that you have to move past
the large numbers to small stories and
remember who you're helping and the
issue here is twofold one is you know
trying to make system change is really
hard and frustrating and sometimes I
know none of you have felt this but
sometimes I felt like well maybe I
should be doing something else I don't
know it's the it's a little too
frustrating and no one's nothing's
moving despite a lot of trying to get
effort so the way that I refresh my
enthusiasm is to think about people's
lives and think about individuals rather
than statistics because when you start
focusing on those individuals than you
can recapture the enthusiasm about what
the work is really trying to do but the
other thing is that a big part of your
job big part of my job when I'm trying
to make this is to motivate people and i
found that motivating people with
statistics is a lot more difficult than
voting fading people with one good story
of one person's life and what what it's
like in what it could be and so again
i'm just sort of reflecting on sort of
what i learned in this process because
when i was in school everything was
about saying oh don't you can't trust an
individual story you must verify it with
large statistics and so forth but what I
learned was a greater respect for those
actual stories the individuals lives who
are touched in and that has also helped
me think about solutions because it made
it very much more concrete what we were
talking about this was a number two that
was an insight to me in doing this and
you heard this just in from Arielle but
it it is I think in some ways the
central focus of much of the work that
Betsy and I have done together which is
paying as much attention to the how oh I
didn't write this and good English thing
about you never mind this is my phone
but it's paying as much attention to the
hell as to the what it's not your
English it's my English it's not good I
typed it too fast but this is something
which is missing so much in the United
States so here's the typical paradigm in
the United States if you're a medical
student I know we have a mix of
physicians and non-physicians here so
for the non-physicians you know we go
through rigorous I'd acted over the
first couple years and it's all about
the what and the assumption is if I tell
you what to do that is how to treat this
or how to treat that or you understand
the pathophysiology of disease and you
understand that this is a pill to treat
something that that's that can stop
there that it's not any emphasis on
actually how you would get this done or
that there might be variation in its
application or the way in which it's
done and so this has become a central
focus of ours which is that okay we need
a good what to do that science has to be
solid about what's the right thing but
also as equally solid has to be a
strategy and understanding and success
in how to do it and how to do it in what
we've discovered is that the same what
applied over various different places
can create very different results
because of how its applied so what's
what's an example of that well I can do
a study of blood pressure pills and
publish it in the most famous journals
and tell you that this pill is a great
pill but then a funny thing happens when
I look across multiple committees and
see a variable degree of success in
treating blood pressure in a variable
degree of outcomes of the patients are
going to see their each of those
patients hoping to get the very best
care each of those patients hoping that
the very best knowledge will be applied
to them and the result being very
different I had this experience in the
how
with we have these very expensive
defibrillators that we put in people's
hearts they're like $25,000 there and we
have many studies that tell us who
should get them in order to prevent
sudden death so people who get fatal
arrhythmia and we can put these boxes
and then it will shock them back to life
and there's some clear guidance from the
studies and there's also some areas
where there's a little uncertainty if
you poll doctors you'll see a wide range
of opinions about how they actually use
them despite the very strong evidence of
who benefits what this means is that
some clinics and other words a place
that I was looking at if you have an
appointment on Monday you may get a very
different recommendation than if you
have an appointment on Wednesday or in
the morning versus the afternoon because
you may see a different doctor they
haven't paid any attention to how
they're going to implement that
knowledge and everyone is doing it their
own way based on whatever their opinion
was and the patient has no knowledge
that if they would have come in in the
afternoon rather than the morning they
might have gotten a different
recommendation there's no
standardization we have uh oh my gosh
look at this I got two number twos
who's doing these slides okay I'm maybe
I did on purpose to see if you're awake
maybe I just made that up I don't know
no but the other thing is that we are
often looking for the solutions within
the community that already exists we
have many constraints if I tell you how
to do something that requires more
resources than you have more expertise
than you have greater workforce and
competence than what you have it doesn't
help you much that's why we've been
going to this approach is one of our
strategies to say has someone within our
community found a way to excel with the
resources that are available today in if
they have what can we learn from them
and how can we disseminate that across
so that we are always looking for new
ways innovative ways maybe ways that are
going to take advantage of technology in
the way we haven't in the past so we're
not stopping that but if we have people
within our community with the resources
available today who are excelling we
need to understand that measurement
matters this is just the continual
emphasis on saying that we have to track
what we're doing you're getting that
pressure from a lot of different places
anyway but in our country I can tell you
there's so much that's invisible because
we do not measure it and there's no
better way to avoid scrutiny into and to
avoid any opportunity to improve than to
have something being visible and have no
idea what the performance is that's the
situation we have in our country for
most things in medicine we have no idea
we don't measure its invisible and if
it's invisible you cannot draw attention
to improving it it's a critical part the
outstanding performance takes teamwork
this is again the notion that i think
the very best work only comes out of
tightly integrated teams with expertise
across a spectrum of areas who have a
commitment to work together it is not
about a single hero it is about how
people work together there can be an
inspiring single person
in our country Obama fills a purpose but
it is his underlying team that's
actually producing the results the
speeches are good for inspiration but
they are meaningless without the actual
tactical implementation of a strategic
plan and that's actually his brilliance
his campaign in this country was
brilliant because of the way it was run
not he did not win because of his
ability to make speeches as good as he
is he won because of the tactical
success of his campaign team and if he
passes revolutionary legislation in
health care here it will be because of
the tactical success of the teen not
because of the speeches this is a
picture are many of you fans of the
Olympics you see them sometimes so
United States had the four three of the
four fastest men in the world in not the
china pics the ones before in where were
they huh Oh after jiu Athens yeah that's
right and you know that we were going to
win this relay so easily because these
guys were so fast I mean this was they
already put up the gold medal in the
United States because these guys that
people figured there was no way they
were going to lose but they lacked the
one thing which was the teamwork broke
down and you know they dropped the baton
so that's awful for them because they
spend so much time preparing but it was
good lesson for us you can have the
fastest guys or women but they won't
produce the best result unless they are
really working together well this is
something which I know you know well but
we also have to think about in our
country to which is change takes courage
and political skill you know the status
quo is the status quo for a reason there
are many people who are doing quite okay
with the status quo it is a comfortable
existence for many people or it wouldn't
exist the way it is and when you start
to talk about change you are threatening
someone
and you've got to both be willing to
step out and try to make the change even
for something as small as trying to
improve care for heart attacks I mean
inconveniencing people getting them to
think differently and it takes political
skill you have to align the coalition's
so that people cannot slow it down or
stop it because it makes so much sense
this is a picture of a very famous event
in our country july second 1964 it was a
time when our president at that time
lyndon johnson signed the civil rights
legislation in this picture you see
martin luther king among all these
mostly white men legislators who Lyndon
Johnson was able to navigate through
legislation that said we would no longer
allow discrimination in this country you
know even in 1964 in this country
there's well even today but but in 1964
in laws you know there were highly
discriminatory laws and this put an end
to that and it was a remarkable feat by
a president to navigate this because he
has to he has to disturb the status quo
he has to say this isn't going to work
anymore now it's a remarkable leadership
by Martin Luther King also but the
interesting thing by Johnson they said
when he put down the pen he said the
Democrats have lost the south for a
generation he knew that actually there
was going to be a large part of the
United States that would never vote for
his party as long as they were alive
because they so were against the idea of
equal rights I mean it seems it's so
offensive but it's true and he had and
he was right the Democrats did not win
the south again for generation even now
some of those states are hard to win but
but he said it's the right thing to do
and he did it so what are our case
studies I just want to show you some
examples of things that at least we've
been involved in and may may give you
some ideas about what you were try to do
so
this is a drug i'm going to give you
examples in cardiology it's the place
where i've done the most work in but I
think as I said the themes relate so
this is a drug propranolol beta blocker
of drug that blocks certain substances
the body which will cause the heart to
be stronger and faster and this is a
picture of the figure that was in the
journal that showed that if you give
this drug to people who have had heart
attacks that you can improve their
outcomes and what this is showing is
cumulative mortality over 30 months of
follow-up and the group that got the
pill had much better than the people who
got placebo and this pill by the way led
to uh there was a fellow sir james black
who got a nobel prize for this pill and
actually another another pillow it's too
much fanfare and its success so there
would be no greater thing than the
invention of this pill we can improve
heart attack outcomes the guy who
doubted did who did it got much
accolades much success from it won the
Nobel Prize and everyone thought that
this will we were done this is all the
what the result really was a twenty
percent improvement in survival most of
us would appreciate if we have a heart
attack to get a pill we can take every
day that would give us a twenty percent
reduction in risk within twenty percent
improvement in our likelihood of
survival it's pretty good and so we knew
the what so I almost every textbook of
medicine that you looked at had quickly
incorporated this into their chapters on
how to treat heart attacks and this
knowledge was being codified and taught
and it was on our tests when we became
doctors and when we became cardiologists
and so there was no controversy within
the entire field about the value of this
pill and so this is it you know this is
how medicine was and so we could say we
can stop now because we can go to the
next problem because we've we've got
this problem solved but ten years after
the trial was published ten years after
that knowledge was consolidated and
people knew what the right thing to do
was this was a situation
we had in our country so this map of the
United States and the Alaskan why you
really aren't that close to California
but they're out here somewhere but I
have to pull them in for the slide just
so you know I in case you wonder about
my geography but so in each of the
states we looked at how we were doing
with this this was part of a government
study where we actually took every
patient hospitalized with a heart attack
who is in our Medicare group which is 65
and older and we reviewed their charts
220,000 medical charts were reviewed and
we said how are we doing on this use of
this drug among other questions we ask
other questions too and this is what we
found by state that by the way the
average in the country was fifty percent
of people were getting the drug fifty
percent of people who had no
contraindication no reason not to get
the drug we went through the charts any
reason that was documented why they
might not get the drug we took we took
them out we didn't consider them so only
the people in this study we kept in were
people who had absolutely no reason not
to get it what they we called them ideal
candidates for the drug perfect
candidates for the drug fifty percent
one of two in this country we're getting
at 1995 more than 10 years in 1981 1982
is when the studies were published so in
the mid-1980s is when the textbooks are
writing about it 1995 this is what we
find and we're doing some of the best in
New England this is Connecticut right
here you're right here but good meant
maybe only three-quarters of the people
were getting it the best states three
out of four were getting one out of four
was not in the worst states only
one-third about one out of three were
getting it there was no reason for this
people are being exposed to the same
health care knowledge the medical
schools were teaching the same thing we
didn't have robe medical schools who
were saying well we don't believe those
studies everyone believed him but this
is where the disconnect occurred
this is where we are now this is what
happened so here were fifty percent his
colors didn't turn out so well but I'm
just showing you what our recent numbers
are two thousand four five five six six
seven seven eight we are now almost at a
hundred percent in the country of the
people who don't have a contraindication
to this medication wow that is really a
remarkable story and I think it starts
this is our beginning of an appreciation
for how you bring about this change but
the lessons I talk to you about in the
beginning are part of it but to me there
were two key things in this story that
are worth talking about one is that
measurement did really matter now part
of this lesson is that it can't be all
about the measurement if you're spending
all of your energy measuring in none of
your energy trying to improve then it
doesn't help it's not about the
measurement but measurement can break
the trance he has no trance I mean you
know people are hypnotized in a way
they're they're thinking in a certain
way and the numbers particularly if
they're done well by the way no matter
what numbers you put up people fight the
numbers at first they can't believe the
numbers they don't coincide with their
experience if you would have asked the
doctors before we measured what percent
of those patients are you treating what
do you think they'd say yeah all of them
I didn't have one doctor said you know I
knew we were only treating half the
people I didn't have one and we talked
to lots of people when we first start
publishing this information I mean I you
know I would get hate mail oh that can't
be true you know I know that's not true
we said people go through stages you
know in the first stage is denial you
know where they say they can't believe
it you know in the final stage you know
it's like these stages I know you've
heard this the you know stages of death
or the final thing is acceptance you
know it's a they finally accept the
information I'd say death because there
was this woman kubler-ross who wrote
stages of
way people handle news about terminal
illness we don't mean to trivialize that
but the point is when people here in
these kind of numbers they can't believe
it and this really sold me on the idea
that you need to be able to defend
numbers on performance to get people to
focus on improvement and so we went
through a period of discussions where we
recognize this as a national problem and
led ultimately to public reporting of
these rates what you're seeing now what
I just showed you in terms of those
numbers those are being publicly
reported in the United States you can go
on a website and find the numbers and
see exactly what each hospital is doing
with regard to their performance that
ended up being a strong incentive for
them not to ignore this problem because
it was embarrassing publicly
embarrassing if they couldn't get their
numbers to where they needed to be the
other thing is the power of partnerships
and dissemination which is the other key
to this was once we started talking
about this problem there began to be in
an outpouring of networking around how
to solve the problem and within the
space we also notice that some place
we're doing better than others and there
was a sharing of knowledge and
information I'm going to get a little
more into a further example but I just
wanted to give you this as a background
as we begin to move from saying well we
can save more lives by making a new
invention or finding a new pill but gosh
we are not getting everything we could
get out of what we've already learned
and by beginning to network hospitals
and beginning to get exchange of
information we could start this effort
to improve and that was another valuable
piece to this part it is an amazing
thing that would I really think without
the measurement we would be in the exact
same performance as we were in 95 and
then without this part the networking
collaboration coordination among
institutions that were driving
improvement from various different
sectors we would also be there so I'm
giving example I'm going to go
to a little more depth about this issue
about deriving the key strategies so I
want to talk to about this example of an
ST segment elevation my Karl infarction
you know I told you I was cardiologist
so kind of stuck with these cardiology
examples but I did bring a picture to
make sure that we're all clear so what
we think happens in a heart attack or
pretty sure happens at a heart attack so
this is a an artery to the heart and you
get these sort of lumps and bumps on the
walls that represent where cholesterol
and some white blood cells build up and
can sometimes impede flow block flow but
oftentimes they are small enough so that
you don't even know and the Bloods
flowing enough but they are there there
and every once in one of them can crack
and when they crack it exposes the
inside to the bloodstream and it causes
a blood clot to form and that blood clot
right here blocks the artery and so the
blood can't get down and the part of
heart muscle that needs the blood is
suddenly deprived of oxygen and
nutrients and that muscle can die and
that's what a heart attack is so you
have the blood vessels feeding the heart
and at one part all of a sudden you can
get a blood clot form that blocks the
blood flow and can cause the damage and
we have actually some drugs that can
break up blood clots once we know people
are having heart attacks but we also
have some techniques procedures that can
do that and what we know is that these
are the first two pictures I showed you
before when it's called ST segment
elevation because of the way the
electrocardiogram looks it's elevated
this part of the is elevated but you get
the blood clot if you go in with an
angioplasty balloon or with a stent you
can push open that blood clot and
restore the blood flow so someone has an
immediate unfortunate event the blood
flow stops you can go in rapidly restore
the blood flow actually if you get in
there fast enough it will be as if
never occurred because the whole problem
is because of a plumbing problem if you
can unclog the plumbing you fix the
problem i know my colleagues who do
these procedures they don't like me to
say that but they're just plumbing but
the thing is unlike your drain it
doesn't matter if you call the plumber
today or tomorrow it's inconvenient if
your heart is in jeopardy is at risk
then actually time matters and you can
imagine the faster you open it after
it's formed the better people do this is
a figure that we published it just shows
this is a there's a measure that we use
which is how long does it take from the
time you come to the door of the
hospital to the time that they open that
artery how long does it take and what we
found was the faster they open it this
is mortality here this is what percent
of people die the faster they open it
the lower the mortality well it makes
sense if I have a blockage in my heart's
being deprived of blood flow every
minute is causing more damage and
causing bigger problems and for some
people it sort of opens and closes it
doesn't immediately close but so you
need to get in there before it
completely closed off and causes the
damage so imagine what somebody today
anyone anyone you met on the street you
know they have a heart attack they might
want to know well if I go to the
hospital my going to be treated quickly
I have a heart attack that might be
important to them I think it would be
important to me but here's what we found
in terms of our performance across the
country I'm just going to take a minute
on this slide so these are four years 99
2000 2001 2002 now you may think I made
a mistake again on the slides because
they all look the same but that's
because our system was so good we had
such a good system that it was getting
the same result every year you know this
is a part people say we've got to
decrease variation in practice well we
didn't have any variation in practice
that doesn't mean that's good enough we
had no variation on very poor practice
people were Marvel how did you create a
system that didn't change I said well
we're very good at bad performance it's
a but what this shows is the green are
the percent of patients that were being
treated within 90 minutes an hour and a
half by the way our guidelines said you
should at least be treated within an
hour and a half that's the most time it
should take because this is a
life-threatening situation and you
should be able to do that the yellow is
well additionally up to two hours the
red is what percent of patients are
taking more than two hours to be treated
from the time they came to the front
door of the hospital through the time
that they were opening that artery and
it was a third and every year was a
third and a third and a third and a
third more than two hours and when we
started looking like even at our own
place we were two and a half hours at
yale-new Haven Hospital in 1998 two and
a half hours and we started looking at
this and trying to understand it and say
wow you know people were fighting over
who was going to transport the patient
and people were like you know there was
no protocol it was every time someone
would come in it would be reinvented the
process that they would be taken care of
who would call who would they call I'll
tell you just one other quick story we
would sometimes fight over the doctor
who would call doctor and someone would
come in and they would say well I think
they have a general doctor so we don't
want to they don't have a cardiologist
yet so we don't want to call the
cardiologist because the general doctor
might get mad so they would try to find
the general doctor and then the general
doctor get on the phone and then they
would take some time and maybe even they
would come in and see the patient they
say yeah this needs a cardiologist and
then they would I'm not kidding I wish I
was and then the cut then they would try
to decide with the cardiologist now
sometimes in our country the referral is
like a gift because they're they're
trying to figure out who they want to
give the gift to because and maybe
sometimes it's even those specialists
are giving you know holiday
back to the generalist or something so
they have relationships that they're
trying to do so if who I wonder who I
should call today okay i think i'll call
this person and by the time they got
that's for two and a half hours one
sometimes three hours i was just saying
this is my little interlude on the
slides but there was a time when people
said it is impossible for us to go
faster we are all moving really quickly
we're top professionals we cannot go
faster we heard that so many times I
have my own institution we cannot they
said follow us around we are busy and we
are working hard and everyone is
focusing on doing the best job we can we
cannot go faster than two and a half
hours that's what they told us many
times they told us that so I was just
said I like this you know in English we
often say nothing is impossible but then
a deed is took this and the possible is
nothing for the Olympic ad campaign I
always liked these these slides I don't
know if you saw these but there's some
of my favorite but I also like the idea
that impossible is nothing there will be
many people who tell you something is
impossible that tells you probably
you're onto something it's something
important and the stronger they tell you
it's impossible the more the more you
can be confident that there's something
there it's worthwhile and we're thinking
about but anyway I thought whoever made
this ad campaign they it was nice not
only because there is the appearance of
someone excelling but it's everyone
behind that person to make that success
possible so this is what we saw when we
really look closely at all the hospitals
and this is worth the Betsy and I did
with a team of people we also worked on
the beta-blocker work together and what
we saw was that this is interesting
there's some hospitals in the united
states that were going quite fast not
only under the 90 minutes but actually
some really doing much better than that
and that there were some that were much
worse than that and this is in I think
2002
or something like that by that time
yale-new Haven Hospital was a little bit
better actually we're starting on a real
path towards improvement but there's
still some out here very long and we
stared at the figure for a long time
because we were very interested in this
group and this is where we said gosh we
can talk about people saying we need
more money to do better okay we're doing
the best we can but if you give us more
money will do better or if you I don't
know change something we'll do better
but we said with the resources that
already exist in our system our health
care system there's some that are really
doing well and we were asking ourselves
the question what made the difference
what was it that will that enable these
institutions to have truly outstanding
performance how did they do it and that
became of central focus of ours because
we thought well there are lots of ways
to try to improve the time I mean maybe
one way is to invent something new that
I don't know some new clock that or some
new something i don't know i mean this
was going to be strictly how did they
move the patient how did they diagnose
the patient and move the patient to the
definitive treatment in a rapid way and
we were very interested in this and so
this is a we ought to begin to identify
several key strategies we went out and
visited the top performers I will tell
you when we visited them no one was ever
surprised that we were visiting them
because they were top we would call them
up and say can we visit you and they say
yeah we do this really well it was never
an accident they didn't ever said wow
that's a surprise we didn't expect that
they all said yeah we're really good at
this we know we're good at this we've
worked at this and then we found that
they commonly had instituted systems
that were going to be able to help them
they let the emergency medicine doctor
begin the process instead of calling so
many doctors to make the decision they
said well that you're a doctor too why
can't you decide that this is a heart
attack that needs to go to the cath lab
why do we have to have several people
coming through to make that decision and
we had
through all of these but they were
examples at some places like our place
maybe how many phone calls did you have
to make to get everybody organized maybe
some places that you had to make ten
phone calls so imagine dr. goes in says
you have a heart attack you need an
emergency procedure we have to move as
quickly as possible and then what was
the next thing they did they went to a
phone and started you know who do I come
first oh yeah then they call one person
maybe that person wasn't even the person
on call because the schedule isn't very
good not reliable even to tell who's on
call okay oh I gotta call the second
person and then what about the person in
the cath lab who's got a what about the
nurses what about transport I mean I'm
serious or someplace told us they had to
make ten calls how long do you think
that takes for a doctor to sit there
trying to find the numbers and get the
people and then sometimes people are
arguing well are you sure this is the
diagnosis and call me back in five
minutes and tell me what happened those
things are unacceptable that was not
what was happening at the best places
best places mergency doctor make them
made the diagnosis one phone call
activate multiple people to come in and
fix it people can come in within 20 to
30 minutes and they're ready to go in
that they were all providing feedback
every time somebody came through they
gave the numbers he knew what the
results were we also discovered that
culture was dominant and so that there
were specific things that were being
done but they also nurtured a culture
where there was a commitment to that
excellence so that they would embrace
the suggested changes so I only says I'm
going to not I should I could spend a
whole hour lingering on this topic but
well I think what we've learned very
well is you have to pay attention to the
context by that I mean what's going on
at the place what are the value system
how are people working together in
addition to the specific things that
they're doing it's that combination the
very best places we visited we're doing
certain things but they also had a
culture
that meant that they were going to
embrace the idea of trying to excel and
that's the most difficult thing we've
thought about which is how do you
nurture that because it's important
component of this we also work to the
launch a national campaign and we
actually signed up hospitals all around
the country in the united states to join
a commitment to improving these times
and adopting the science that had been
done what i showed you before was art
science trying to figure out what we
could recommend to people published in
New England Journal of Medicine but we
were not content to stop there we had to
get it apply so with aligning ourselves
with influential organizations in the
country professional organizations
doctors organizations Hospital
organizations patient organizations we
were able to sign up three-quarters of
the hospitals that perform this
procedure in the country and all across
our country they they join the effort
they made an explicit commitment to try
to improve times and these are the kind
of things that people would send us who
join this effort this is a I think this
is from a hospital in South Carolina and
they sent me that this was their run
chart that when they started they were
at about two hours and overtime this is
was launching of the campaign they
improved a little bit to here and then
they improve further down to almost 60
minutes one hour somebody came in their
front door and needed this procedure
they could now get it in one hour
instead of two this was going to save
lives and we saw things like this this
is from a friend of mine at the Mayo
Clinic and what they would do is people
around the country these hospitals would
start trying new things and then because
we had this network of a thousand
hospitals we could disseminate good
ideas quickly now people didn't always
have to pick up all the ideas but they
could consider them and think about what
they want to do this is what Mayo Clinic
does every time a patient would come
through and it would only be a couple
times a week in general they would send
out
email to all the people who might care
for these patients and they would say
they would hide the name patient mmm
then they would say what the date was
and what time did they come in this is
for 42 in the morning when did they get
the electrocardiogram when did they
activate the cath lab that meant when
did they say to the lab we're going to
bring somebody up when did the patient
leave the emergency department and when
did they have the procedure and what
were the times okay they came in it took
us four minutes to get an
electrocardiogram another six minutes to
decide so what we were going to do
actually these are I think six so this
is cumulative they got the
electrocardiogram it's only two minutes
later they look at the electrocardiogram
they say okay I know what we've got so
within six minutes of coming in the
front door they have identified this
patient as having a heart attack that
needs this emergency procedure that's
something that might have taken 45
minutes at my institution in 1997 took
them six minutes patient leaves so the
cath lab has to be ready for them then
they leave and they they get it within
58 minutes they say who are the people
involved and then they give any notes
because sometimes there are delays that
are not system delays maybe they have to
do with the patient patient needs so
they can explain it but every time a
patient comes through everybody gets
this note it focuses them on the
performance it focuses them on the
teamwork it focuses and what they need
to accomplish on what they have
accomplished here's where we are right
now in the country first quarter of 2008
now three quarters of the patients are
being treated within 90 minutes and
we're getting a lot of reports of people
being treated within 45 minutes and 50
minutes but three quarters remember I
said this was the number that as late is
2001 and I can take 2002 2003 only a
third of patients were being treated
this fast and it continues to improve
what we're almost at ninety percent
now I can tell you actually the number
shouldn't be a hundred percent because
there are some patients who come in with
more than one problem maybe they also
have had trauma and actually you have to
attend to that first there may be some
things even more important than the
heart attack so we don't actually expect
to get to one hundred percent but it's
an example of what's equipped what has
occurred in this country through the
science of trying to understand the what
and the how and then the political
process of aligning the forces to make
this an irresistible opportunity for
improvement and I should mention also
publicly reported these are on the
website you can see what the hospital's
success rates are in treating people
quickly this is a major major success
for us and we're still trying to learn
all the lessons from it because it still
took too long to make this happen how
can we shorten the cycle times to make
this kind of improvement but this is one
thing that's happened that's very
gratifying I can't completely tell you
exactly how it happened but I have some
ideas but in the period from 1995 to
2006 there were in general no major new
breakthroughs in cardiovascular medicine
for the acute treatment of mi there were
some new anticoagulants that were put
out we're using more angioplasty but in
general in general there was no
breakthrough that occurred but we
focused a lot on quality we focused on
improving our systems of care we focused
on the kind of things that I've been
showing you getting people the right
medications at the right time making
sure we're giving more timely care
focusing a lot on safety issues and
communication issues this is what
happened in the country this is a
histogram these are a number of
hospitals so the height of the bars
represent number of hospitals this is
the 30-day risk standardized mortality
rate so this is taking into account how
sick the patients are in your
institution we estimate your more tech
watching mortality rate is that's your
performance and look at this this these
light bars which are hard to see what
extent like to hear
so this is the this is the distribution
of hospital performance in 1995 the 30
day for Medicare beneficiaries that's
those people 65 and older the 30-day
risk standardized mortality rate was
about nineteen percent in some hospitals
were as high as 24 25 percent and at the
low end we were around sixteen percent
so the spread is almost ten point more
than 10 points what does that mean that
means for every ten patients admitted to
one of these hospitals instead of one of
these hospitals there's an additional
death that's pretty big pretty big
spread it means that your chance of
survival from a heart attack is
contributed to not only by how severe
your heart attack is but by which
hospital you go to that there are
differences by hospital in your
likelihood of survival and look what
happened by 2006 we shifted the entire
performance curve so that what was good
performance in nineteen into that in
1995 now is not that good at performance
in 2006 if you stood still as a hospital
at your performance that you are now
lagging you're lagging you're not doing
well you could have been an outstanding
performer in 95 if you stayed the same
place there's nothing special about you
now and the whole curve this is when
we're saying in this country we were not
going to only look we an expression we
were not looking for bad apples we
weren't just looking for the one person
or the one hospital that was just doing
everything awful and killing people we
were looking to make entire system
change so that the entire assumptions of
performance were going to shift and
we're going to shift everyone we weren't
just going to say we have to look at
these hospitals and fix them we said we
are not happy with this distribution
we've got to improve the performance of
everyone we've got to shift this entire
perform
and figure out how we're going to do
that the focus on outcomes is also
important because I can tell you that
let's measure time and time is important
we should focus on time I can tell you
we should focus on beta blockers but
from a patient perspective our bottom
line are more people surviving because
if they're not then we have to question
our assumptions about what we're doing
and the other places where we think we
know we're confident that if we do this
then that should be better we have to at
the end of the day ask what's happened
to patients not have they got more pills
not have they gotten treated faster but
do we have evidence at the end of the
day that they actually are doing better
I would love to have actually quality of
life data so i can know even more
completely if i bettered people not me
is a group you know everyone working on
us if we can know that we've bettered
people's lives but certainly the
survival to me is at least one
indication that there have been
improvements in the system so last just
take a few minutes on this I wanted to
just go through for a second the this
issue about the positive deviance and
some of the things we have I don't know
about so if we've distributed that paper
they have the paper so I just was going
to go through a little bit it is one of
the fundamental pieces I am all for the
invention and discovery of very new
approaches that don't currently exist
and the savvy use of information
technology to leverage our efforts so I
don't want you to think that our
commitment to positive deviance is in
any way in any way a lack of enthusiasm
for new discovery but it does also
allows us to discover within what's
currently going on ways that may have
beneficial approaches so the positive
deviance is you know we identify was we
identified these positive deviants and
then X these are organizations that
consistently demonstrate exceptionally
high performance in an area of interest
and then we study them in depth using
qualitative methods to generate
hypotheses about practices we we
actually do this in a rigorous fashion
to say what can we learn from them and
how can we begin to think about
what's really making them excellent now
it could be that it's a Miss it's it's
really has nothing to do with them it
could be that for some reason either the
way that we're evaluating him or the
kind of patients that they have or
there's something about them that's not
about how they they would do the work
but maybe just maybe it's actually they
figured something out that can be
generally applicable across the entire
community we want to know that but we
also want to test this we want to see
what happens if the other places start
adopting this will it matter and can we
work in partnership with other people
call key stakeholders other people with
interest in this including potential
adopters to disseminate the information
the final step is not just the insight
not just the knowledge but then how can
we work to apply it and make it stick
right get people excited about it and
then incorporated we want the effort to
improve to have to go away because the
way of doing things has become so
embedded that it's just the way we they
work now so it's not that you have to
have a constant infusion of energy and
focus on it my hope on the timeliness of
treatment is that in the places that
have improved you can abandon the
quality improvement team they have to
continue to monitor results but they are
at a new equilibrium they're at a new
standard of performance because the way
they've changed the system um there are
just a couple of other things we learned
particularly the beta blocker piece that
we're very beneficial for success and I
just wanted to list them for you because
I have been advocating to say it's
almost not worth doing a project unless
you can check off these attributes of
the project one can you articulate a
specific goal I've been on so many
projects where the goal is so vague I
mean it's very inspiring to improve
health or to improve outcomes to improve
heart heart attack care but it doesn't
help me I need more specificity I need
more precision in language to know what
exactly
are we trying to do and if anyone on the
team has asked on the street what are
you doing they can say in one sentence
here's what we're trying to do in the
case of door-to-balloon in case of that
timeless we said we want 75% of the
hospitals to be treating patients on
average less than 90 minutes everybody
knew that that's what we were trying to
do was in our top we were very specific
we said that's our goal and we can we
tried to get there and when we saw
hospitals that excelled they had put
very specifically what they were trying
to do they could have a larger goal of
what they're all of their efforts are
intended to accomplish but in health
care I think we have to get very
concrete very specific administrative
support is it you or is there really
someone behind you that has power in the
organization in the country who believes
in it because the more it's you as a
singular cheerleader well they're always
the possibility for a remarkable
individual to make change I mean I'm not
sure Gandhi had much administrative
support but I don't know how many
Gandhi's there are for sustained
embedded change in general for us normal
mortal people unless there may be some
Gandhi's here which would be really
great but even Gandhi probably would
have benefited from more administrative
support this is a key feature our people
behind you because if they're not what
are their priorities because you have to
make sure you're a line or you may be
wasting your time clinician leaders at
least here in the States we're convinced
you have to have some people who are
actually involved in the day-to-day
delivery of care I'd say clinician I
don't say physician physician is
important too but so are nurses all
health care professionals people who
know what it's like to do the daily work
because there are two pieces to that
they bring credibility to the effort and
they bring good ideas because they know
what it's like to be
on the front lines delivering the care
and they so they bring a sense of
reality to the effort that's trying to
be made you have to ground Betsy and I
when we did the research with our team
it's all it's everything we talked about
his team base it's not us alone it's the
team we found many things that could
improve the times a couple of the things
we're things that would not be adopted
by every hospital in the country if we
wanted to really promote everything that
would improve then we would have been
promoting some things that we knew would
never be adopted one of them if you have
a cardiologist who stays in the hospital
all the time they were faster four
percent of our hospitals have employed a
cardiologist to be in the hospital 24 7
through shifts they go very fast because
they have someone who's there there's no
way in this country you're going to
convince people to do that if we had
taken that on as a strong recommendation
we would have met so much resistance I
think it would have disabled and
unraveled the project we had to give up
with some of that because people on the
front lines they reflected to us don't
make don't do that we don't want to it's
not going to happen we will fight you on
that it wasn't a fight worth having
because if we could get everything else
we were going to get most of what we
wanted it was ok systems approach it's
not about the fault of an individual
it's about the system in which they
operate now we still need clinicians who
are highly skilled and who are committed
to the right values but in the wrong
system there's no one who can excel no
one who can excel in to the right system
we ought to make it so it's easy to
excel any athlete who wants to do well
is surrounded any team that wants to do
well in sports they have systems set up
to in order to foster that success it's
in the individual who's out those
systems and just tries to do it on their
own is that a great disadvantage and
measurement I've said this over and over
again again not for measurements sake
but as a tool this is again another
paper which
they have this paper the beta-blocker
paper we might send you this paper that
goes over some of these issues so the
final thing is again you know I think
that I know this long lecture and
there's so much to absorb in this time
and I'm so deeply grateful for your
commitment to try to make the
contributions that you're making in your
countries you know the challenges in
your country you know the brain drains
in your country the fact that you can
remain committed to your countries and
the time you're spending and the ability
to withstand the frustrations and
challenges and yet your commitment to
continue to try to make a difference
there I think makes you heroes in my
eyes because it's easy for you to have
taken a different path and you yet
you've chosen to do a difficult path but
one that has the possibility of making
such an important impact and I think
again you know remember who you're
helping it must must be at the forefront
of this because I don't know how else
you can sustain your your strength
through what are some very challenging
efforts and you know so Muhammad Ali you
know impossible is nothing but we all
wish you success in your journey as you
go back and try to apply these and we
look forward to seeing the successes
that you have and hope you remember
fondly the time you spend here thank you